el cerco se cierra alrededor de
ese fue el mensaje transmitido por el
fundador del grupo paramilitar ruso
Wagner en un vídeo publicado el viernes
se dirigió directamente al presidente
ucraniano
las unidades del grupo Wagner han
rodeado efectivamente backmud Solo queda
un camino las pinzas se están cerrando
anteriormente luchábamos contra el
ejército profesional ucraniano pero hoy
nos enfrentamos cada vez más a los
ancianos y los niños están luchando
contra nosotros pero sus vidas en
backmooth son cortas uno o dos días
denles la oportunidad de salir de la
ciudad la ciudad está realmente rodeada
[Música]
el vídeo muestra a tres ucranianos
capturados pidiendo que les dejen volver
a casa si bajmukae sería la primera Gran
Victoria de Moscú en medio año durante
meses Wagner ha encabezado el asalto a
la ciudad y una vez fue el hogar de
alrededor de 7
personas ahora la mayoría de la
población se ha ido algunos han huido a
un territorio que ahora está bajo
control ruso aquí en este Refugio a unas
dos horas al sur de bahamut el líder
separatista de
duninas que habían abandonado
recientemente su ciudad esta familia
dice que fueron evacuados por
combatientes de Wagner
estábamos esperando la evacuación porque
no queríamos ir a Ucrania queríamos ir a
Rusia
esperaron y ocurrió esperamos en los
sótanos
el control del ejército ucraniano sobre
la ciudad parece Ahora más tenue que
nunca el viernes temprano por la mañana
el comandante de una unidad ucraniana de
aviones no tripulados en bahmud dijo que
se le había ordenado retirarse de la
ciudad